أجنبي
هذا ما تبدو عليه ليبراسيون
[تصفيق
] وهذا ما يشعر
به أهل أغنيتها عصر النشوة ،
شهور الظلام من الاحتلال الروسي القمعي
على
قواتهم ، حيث استقبل
سكانها الأبطال الغزاة المنقطعين عن العالم ، ولا
إنترنت ولا كهرباء ولا ماء.  ولا يوجد
تجمع تلفزيوني في الساحة المركزية بالمدينة
للاستماع إلى
بثنا وإخبارنا كيف كانت الأشهر الثمانية
الماضية وكأنني انضممت هنا من قبل
يوليا وأولغا وسنجري محادثة سريعة
حول كيفية إخبارنا بذلك.  نحن
في الأشهر الثمانية الماضية جوليا تحت
الاحتلال ، لقد كان وقتًا عصيبًا حقًا
للجميع ،
انتظرت كل عائلة أوكرانية
جنودنا لجيشنا ،
فكيف تشعر الآن اليوم برؤيتهم
إنه لأمر مدهش ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك
على دعمنا لنا ،
لقد صورنا كل  يوم دعمك ، شكرًا
جزيلاً ، يمكنني أن أعانقك بالتأكيد
شكرًا جزيلاً لك
[تصفيق]
هل يمكننا التحدث نعم بالتأكيد ، هل يمكنك إخبارنا
بتجاربك على مدار
الثمانية أشهر الماضية  لقد كنا ننتظر طويلاً ولكننا
نحن
شعبنا هنا وفي كل مكان في
العالم شكرًا لكل الكلمات التي
دعمتنا والتي ساعدتنا وهذا اليوم
يسعدنا أن نكون هنا نحن سعداء جدًا
مع شعبنا للاحتفال بهذا
اليوم هذا شيء  مذهل ولكنه كان
صعبًا ، لكننا كنا نعلم دائمًا أن هذا اليوم
سيأتي ، هل تشعر أن المدينة آمنة
الآن ، نعم المدينة آمنة بالنسبة لنا
وأخبرنا كيف كان الأمر لأنه لم يكن
لدينا معلومات جيدة هنا كيف كان
الوضع  العيش مع
الجنود الروس الذين يتحكمون في ما يمكنك
رؤيته هنا الآن ، أعتقد أن العديد منهم
كانوا يخفون العلم الأوكراني
في مكان ما في الزاوية ،
وقد شعرنا
بالرعب من قبل الجيش الروسي ، فقد شعرنا
بالرعب من
الجنود الذين يمكن أن يأتوا في أي لحظة في منطقتنا.
منزل في منزلنا فقط افتح الباب
كأنهم يعيشون هنا
ويختطف الفريق التعذيب وكان هذا
أمرًا حقيقيًا جدًا لدي قشعريرة الآن
عندما أتحدث لكننا فعلنا ذلك ننتظر
ونحتفل الآن
بأفضل ما يكون هذا ما هي
العملية  يبدو أن هذا ما
تشعر به ليبراسيون مثل سكان هذه
المدينة الذين يحاولون مقاومة الروس ،
والروس يقمعونهم ،
هذا ما يشبه الأوكرانيين عندما
يأتي ذلك القمع.